your books strike a chord
strike a chord with me because i see
them as a way
especially for a man as a guide to how
to be successful
as a as a way to make the most of your
life to develop your life to take
responsibility
and all these kind of things and one of
the things that i've seen with men of my
age
i'm in my late 30s i know i look younger
you don't have to say it but
but in my late 30s i see a lot of men
struggling
with what does it mean to be successful
when you when we look at that word
success what does that mean to you
and how would you inspire men of my age
and younger
another late feeling yeah it's too late
for me but to to
actually become a success
well first of all i think it's really
worth thinking about what success
means and i try to do that a lot in in
both the books
um it's really fun to make other people
successful
like that's this is one of the the
reasons capitalism i would say gets a
really bad rap
and an unfair rap like the people i've
known
who have been successful in the
capitalist
enterprise and a lot of them are
entrepreneurs
rather than managers let's say just it's
just that's the population i've been
exposed to
and this was the same among the
professoriate for that matter
one of the great pleasures the people
that i've seen who i respect
took was in mentoring and so
don't underestimate the radical
satisfaction that's associated with
helping other people develop one of the
reasons that good professors
well and good businessmen love to be
in the position they're in is because
they can identify young people who are
promising and
open up doors of opportunity to them
it's really intrinsically motivating
and so you know when you think of
capitalism for example or success as
only a competitive enterprise that's a
real mistake because there's that aspect
of it that's
there everywhere in every enterprise
i've ever seen
so success real success means you're
successful in a way that makes other
people around you successful
you need both of those and that's also
really good for your conscience because
then you're not working at the expense
of anyone else
quite the contrary right you're you're
lifting the tie that lifts all boats and
maybe you're simultaneously elevating
your own relative status but
it's really it's not um unreasonable
to put that in as a constraining
requirement
it has to help other people well it
helps you and i would say
the way we're wired now some people are
more selfish than others
but i would still say human beings are
unbelievably social and reciprocal
that's built into us at an incredibly
deep level
and it can go wrong and we can get
cynical and malevolent and bitter and
and work at counter purposes to it but
to be of service to your fellow
man your family members your broader
community
there are there are virtually no
pleasures that that compete with that
so and and and so that's partly why it
is useful to do a critique of
mere materialism and materialistic
satisfactions are pretty fleeting
they're not non-existent
um but they're they don't have the deep
and
lasting satisfaction of well of
successful mentoring for example
and the relationships that build out of
that so
i think i don't think there is any
success at all without
moral success in fact i think that
success without moral
success is actually a form of torture
you know
if you don't let's say you don't feel
you deserve anything
because you're you know that you're
being you're not being a good person and
that's your own judgment and
let's assume that you're accurate you're
not because some people will judge
themselves far too harshly but let's
just say you know
you have reasons to have your conscience
bothering you
and you're not successful well at least
you don't
feel the continual injustice of that
you think well i'm a son of a [ __ ] but
i don't have anything
but then let's say you're successful
well
you know that's all you'll gotten how
can that do any and then maybe you have
to rationalize constantly to live with
it
everything you collect around you is
nothing but a
source of torment and a constant
reminder that you're
criminal in your fundamental orientation
that you've
ruined people on your mad scramble to
the top
jesus you don't want that like you
seriously don't want that and no amount
of
relative material status is going to
even come
close to rectifying that you want
your conscience to be clean clear you
want your interpersonal relationships to
be
honest you want to be reliable and
dependable and if you can add exciting
and adventurous to that so much the
better
but success means to be successful means
to be
good and you say that successful means
to be good
isn't that a problem whereby where in
society particularly our society
where people judge success they judge it
on the acquirement of property
material goods and possessions and
therefore there's
there's that imbalance where someone can
be morally good and a fantastic
person but in a materialistic society
seem to be a failure because they
haven't acquired a great deal
well that that definitely is a problem
when you have productive people
that that's a problem in how the mon
it's a measurement problem in some sense
you know
economic success is generally associated
with intelligence and conscientiousness
so there is a rough
correlation between ability let's say
even moral ability and success
now i'm not making too much of that but
i do know
look if you're going to be a successful
businessman especially across
business person across multiple
dimensions
multiple enterprises you bloody well
better be honest
because it's going to catch up with you
man and the probability that you're
going to be a successful crook multiple
times is very very low
you can do that but you have to move
constantly
right so your reputation doesn't keep up
with you so
there is some association between
success and
moral virtue thank god but it's
it's it's a rough approximation and
there's plenty of exceptions
it's very hard for creative people to
monetize their productivity for example
so you have unrewarded virtue and that's
a flaw of the monetary system
means we haven't been able to and you
might say the same thing applies to such
things as
our inability to pay home makers
now why don't we pay homemakers well
it's because what they produce
isn't monetizable for 20 years
and our economic system isn't
sophisticated enough to figure out how
to pay people
for returns that are that
you know pushed off into the future that
doesn't make it right
but we don't know how to fix it
technically right
i mean if you're a venture capitalist
and you want to invest in something you
want a
10-fold return on your investment within
a handful of years
you can't afford to invest over a
20-year period and so
that makes it really rough on homemakers
because we're not sophisticated enough
to monetize it
so it's a measurement problem but unless
you can figure out a better way of doing
it
you're stuck with what we've got
you